Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. An address to the French people, your constitution rests on the principles of eternal justice. A League of Kings has been formed in order to destroy it. Their battalions are advancing. Do you not feel a noble ardour arousing your courage? Would you allow foreign hordes to spread like a destroying torrent over your countryside to ravage our harvest, to devastate our
感谢收听《一切皆历史》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先收听各系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。致法国人民的一封信，你们的宪法建立在永恒正义的原则之上。为了摧毁它，一帮国王已经结成了同盟。他们的军队正在推进。难道你们没有感受到一种高尚的热情在激发你们的勇气吗？难道你们要任由外国暴徒像毁灭性的洪流一样漫过你们的乡间，蹂躏我们的庄稼，毁灭我们的
fire and through fire and murder, in a word to fetter you with chains dyed in the blood of those you hold most dear. Make haste citizens save liberty and grasp your glory, the National Assembly declares the homeland is in danger. So that Dominic was La Patrie en danger, which was a decree published by the legislative assembly in July 1792. And it was read out across Paris, alerting the people to the fact that their beloved country was facing invasion and defeat. And in a previous episode, we talked about how France had declared war on basically everybody in a spirit of revolutionary excitement and
战火以及通过战火与谋杀，一言以蔽之，用沾满你们最珍爱之人的鲜血的锁链来禁锢你们吗？公民们，快行动起来，拯救自由，抓住你们的荣耀，国民议会宣布祖国处于危急之中。所以多米尼克，这就是“祖国在危急中”（La Patrie en danger），这是立法议会在1792年7月颁布的一项法令。它在巴黎各地被宣读，向人们发出警报，让他们知道他们深爱的国家正面临着入侵和战败。而在上一期节目中，我们谈到了法国是如何出于一种革命的兴奋和
overconfidence and it's all going wrong. Isn't it? It is going wrong. So Tom, it was lovely to welcome back the right honourable Jeremy Corbyn, who appeared to be reading that. What was going on there? Well, I did think that there was a kind of Corbynite quality to the, to the summons to arms. Okay. And so I wanted to evoke that. What was going on there? Well, I did think that there was a kind of Corbinite quality to the summons to arms. Okay.
盲目的自信，向基本上所有人宣战的，而现在这一切都搞砸了。不是吗？确实搞砸了。所以，汤姆，很高兴欢迎尊敬的杰里米·科尔宾再度做客，他刚才似乎在宣读那段话。那到底是怎么回事？嗯，我确实觉得那份战争动员令有一种科尔宾式的特质。好吧。所以我想唤起那种感觉。那到底是怎么回事？嗯，我确实觉得那份战争动员令有一种科宾式的特质。好吧。
And so I wanted to evoke that. Yeah, you did. I didn't want to do it in a kind of French accent because I thought for our listeners, you know, it's about conveying the sense of urgency and passion that the Legislative Assembly are trying to kind of evoke. So I thought it was quite subtle. Well, yeah, it was lovely and subtle actually. So what is coming, as you, as you rightly said, the 20th of April, they declared war on Austria and they expect an easy victory.
所以我想要唤起那种感觉。是的，你做到了。我并不想用某种法国口音来读，因为我想对我们的听众来说，你知道的，这关乎传达立法议会试图唤起的某种紧迫感和激情。所以我认为这相当微妙。嗯，是的，实际上挺美妙也挺微妙的。所以接下来，正如你——正如你正确指出的那样，4月20日，他们对奥地利宣战，并且他们期待着一场轻松的胜利。
And what happens next will be a fatal blow to the French monarchy. And I think even more significantly, actually, it is the spur to a second French revolution, a second insurrection. And that's what's the subject of today's episode. It will completely change the narrative of the revolution. Now, as you said, the big wigs with whom we entered the last bit of narrative. So that's Briceau, the kind of abolitionist, the social justice activist, sort of metropolitan, habitué of salons and things. Yeah, he loves a highbrow bookshop. He does indeed. So Briceau and Dumouriez, who is the kind of hard-bitten military man who is now the
而接下来发生的事情，将对法国君主制造成致命的一击。而且我认为更具深远意义的是，实际上它是第二次法国大革命、第二次起义的催化剂。这正是今天这期节目的主题。它将彻底改变这场革命的叙事。现在，正如你所说，我们进入上一段叙事时提到的那些大人物们。也就是布里索，那种废奴主义者、社会正义活动家、某种意义上的大都市人、沙龙常客之类的人物。是的，他酷爱高雅的书店。他确实如此。所以布里索和迪穆里耶——迪穆里耶是个饱经沧桑的军人，现在担任
foreign minister, they expect that when their armies cross the border into the Austrian Netherlands, that's what's now Belgium, the locals will rise and support them and basically they'll win an easy victory. And what actually happens is a total and utter catastrophe. So in the preceding weeks, the Austrians had moved 50,000 troops to the frontier in readiness and the French, as soon as they cross the border, it's as though they hadn't expected this at all. They fight two small battles in the first few days, 28th and 29th of April, and they lose both of them in absolutely risible circumstances with kind of as soon as the musket balls or whatever start flying, their troops are literally shouting, Sovkipa, every man for himself, and kind of running away.
外交大臣——他们预计，当他们的军队跨越边境进入奥属尼德兰（也就是现在的比利时）时，当地人会起义支持他们，基本上他们会赢得一场轻松的胜利。而实际发生的事情却是一场彻头彻尾的彻底灾难。因此，在之前的几周里，奥地利人在前线部署了5万名军队做好了准备，而法军刚一跨边境，就好像他们完全没有料到这一幕似的。他们在头几天（4月28日和29日）打了两场小型战役，结果在极其荒谬的情况下两战皆败，伴随着某种一旦火枪子弹之类的东西开始飞舞，他们的士兵就 literalmente（字面意思）在大喊“各人逃命吧”（Sauve qui peut），然后掉头逃跑。
So why? What's happened? Well, I think what has clearly happened, and this is something that Marion Twynet had been telling the Austrians for I think what has clearly happened, and this is something that Marion Twainette had been telling the Austrians for months, discipline in the army had completely collapsed. A lot of the senior officer class had already left France. And because of the revolution, it's actually a very similar story to what happens in 1917 in the Russian revolution, a lot of units just don't obey their officers anyway. So when their officers tell them to charge, they go the opposite way. Even though, presumably the assumption on the part of the Legislative Assembly when they voted for war
那么为什么呢？发生了什么？嗯，我认为显然已经发生的是——这也是玛丽·安托瓦内特几个月来一直在向奥地利人透露的事情——军队的纪律已经彻底崩溃了。许多高级军官阶层已经离开法国。而且由于革命的爆发，这其实非常类似于1917年俄国革命中发生的情况，很多部队根本不服从他们的军官。所以当他们的军官命令他们冲锋时，他们却朝反方向跑去。尽管，据推测立法议会在投票赞成战争时，内心的假设是
was that the people of the Austrian Netherlands would be so grateful to receive their fraternal revolutionary comrades that they would rise up, but they don't. Yeah, this basically doesn't happen. But why are the troops not fired with revolutionary zeal? I think some of the troops are, but don't forget at this point they're advancing onto foreign soil. They're not defending their homeland. So it's a bit of a different story if you advance onto foreign soil, the expected rising
奥属尼德兰的人民会如此感激他们的同胞革命同志，以至于他们会起义，但他们并没有。是的，这基本上没有发生。但为什么军队没有被革命的热情点燃呢？我认为有些部队是有的，但别忘了在这一点上他们正在向外国领土推进。他们不是在保卫自己的祖国。所以如果你向外国领土推进，情况就完全不同了，预期的起义
doesn't happen. The Austrians are there en masse and you're very distrustful of your officers. So there's one incident. So after these two battles at the end of April, outside Tournai, one of the units turns on their colonel and they hang him and then they fire him out of a cannon. You know, lots of the officers say, oh my God, I'm going to be fired out of a cannon next. That's not good.
并没有发生。奥地利人大规模地集结在那里，而且你对自己的军官极不信任。所以发生了一起事件。因此，在4月底在图尔奈（Tournai）进行这两场战斗之后，其中一支部队调转枪口对准了他们的上校，他们把他绞死，然后把他塞进大炮里发射了出去。你知道的，许多军官都说，天哪，下一个被塞进大炮里发射出去的肯定是我。这可不妙。
Not good for discipline at all. And then they turn on their general and he's a man called Théobald Dion and he was a liberal general. He was an ally of Lafayette and he is basically taken by his men to Lille. He's beaten up by a crowd and then he's bayonetted to death in the main square of Lille. And Simon Sharma describes it very pithily in his book. Dion's body was then hanged from a lanterne, his left leg was severed as a trophy and paraded around town before the rest of his corpse was thrown
对纪律来说一点也不妙。然后他们又把矛头指向了他们的将军，这个人叫泰奥巴尔·迪翁（Théobald Dillon），他是一位自由派将军。他是拉法耶特的盟友，结果他被手下的士兵带到了里尔。他在里尔的一群暴民中遭到痛打，然后在里尔的主广场上被刺刀刺死。西蒙·沙玛（Simon Schama）在他的书中非常精辟地描述了这一幕：迪翁的尸体随后被挂在路灯上，他的左腿被砍下来作为战利品在城里游行示威，然后他尸体的其余部分被扔到了
on a bonfire. And Tom, unlike your brother's podcast, We Have Ways, which is the second world war, we're not a military history podcast or indeed a podcast of the history of war, but this strikes me as an unpromising beginning to a military campaign. It's a tremendous tribute to the discipline of the French troops, is it? Not at all. Lots of officers at this point resign. They say, oh my God, I'm next. I don't want to be fired out of Cannondale and have my leg paraded around the square. I'm out.
篝火上。汤姆，与你兄弟的播客《我们有办法》（We Have Ways）——那是关于二战的——不同，我们不是一个军事历史播客，也不是一个战争史播客，但这给我的感觉是一场军事行动一个毫无希望的开端。这真是对法军纪律的巨大“赞誉”，不是吗？一点也不。许多军官在这个时候辞职了。他们说，天哪，下一个就是我。我可不想被塞进卡农戴尔（Cannondale，此处疑为主持人口误或双关）大炮里发射出去，还把我的大腿在广场上游行示威。我不干了。
Including the commander of the entire army of the North, who's a guy called Rochambeau, who was a veteran of Yorktown. So really, I mean, fair do's. That's paretic justice, isn't it? Well, I guess of course it's... Helping rebels against their lawful king. Yeah. What goes around comes around. Yeah. I mean, I don't, I don't wait for him, you know, back the wrong horse and the tax revolt and this is what happens. Now the question I guess is actually, it's not why the French
包括北方军的总司令，一个名叫罗尚博（Rochambeau）的人，他曾是约克镇的功臣。所以说实话，这真是报应不爽，不是吗？嗯，我想当然是的……帮助叛军对抗他们合法的国王。嗯。因果报应，屡试不爽。嗯。我的意思是，我并不，我不替他惋惜，你知道的，押错了宝，参与了减税暴动，结果就是这样。现在问题大概是，其实，不是法军
aren't doing so badly, but why don't the Austrians do even better? And frankly, I think they're taken by surprise at how quickly the French have collapsed because if the Austrians had seized the opportunity, of course, Austrian armies never do, they're all famously kind of deletrient. They could probably have surged over the border and made far greater memories than they do. Anyway, in Paris already, as we have discussed, there is a very, very peculiar mood on the streets. There's a kind of apocalyptic sense of expectation because of this sense of an ideological crusade. There is a paranoid style in politics already, a belief that there's a grand behind everything, there's some grand conspiracy. And that of course has been there since 1789, if not before. And there's this thing that you were talking about about masks, the mask of patriotism.
为什么表现得这么糟糕，而是为什么奥地利人没有表现得更好？坦率地说，我认为他们对法军崩溃的速度感到惊讶，因为如果奥地利人抓住了机会——当然，奥地利军队从不这样，他们历来以拖沓闻名——他们本可以冲过边境，取得比现在大得多的战果。无论如何，在巴黎，正如我们已经讨论过的，街头弥漫着一种非常非常奇特的情绪。由于这种意识形态十字军东征的观念，产生了一种末日般的期待感。政治中已经存在一种偏执的风格，坚信每件事背后都有一个宏大的阴谋。当然，这种心态自1789年以来就一直存在，甚至在此之前就有了。而且还有你之前谈到的那种伪装，爱国主义的面具。
Yeah, the mask of patriotism, exactly. And so as soon as reports of these defeats reach Paris, people basically go completely berserk and the radical papers, so Marat's paper, the people's friend, Lamy du peuple, was a paper of a guy called Hebert called Père de Chene. So Père de Chene is, he's a kind of grumpy old furnace maker who's borrowed from kind of theatres and becomes a mouthpiece for Hebert's politics. And he's quite kind of Trump-esque because he has a fondness for abusive nicknames. So he calls Marie Antoinette Madame Vito and he calls Lafayette, which I thought you would enjoy, General Blondinet.
是的，爱国主义的面具，完全正确。所以一旦这些战败的消息传到巴黎，人们基本上就彻底发疯了。激进的报纸，比如马拉的报纸《人民之友》（L'Ami du peuple），还有埃贝尔（Hebert）的报纸《杜歇老爹》（Père Duchesne）。所以杜歇老爹，他是一个脾气暴躁的旧炉匠，这个形象是从戏剧里借鉴过来的，成为了埃贝尔政治的喉舌。他相当具有特朗普式的风格，因为他酷爱使用侮辱性的绰号。所以他叫玛丽·安托瓦内特“维托夫人”（Madame Veto），他叫拉法耶特——我想你会喜欢的——“金发将军”（General Blondinet）。
Yeah, yeah, he does indeed. And this invective, which has already been there, is reaching this kind of pitch of aggression and sort of scatological obsessions. And the reason that I think there's such an audience for it, and it's important to remember this, is that people are not just frightened now about the defeats, but they're still hungry. So with the declaration of war, economic confidence has further collapsed. The assignee, the paper money is completely
是的，是的，他确实如此。这种本就存在的谩骂，正在达到一种极具攻击性并带有一些排泄物恋物癖色彩的高潮。而我认为之所以会有如此庞大的受众——记住这一点很重要——是因为人们现在不仅对战败感到恐惧，而且他们仍然在挨饿。随着宣战的颁布，经济信心进一步崩溃。指券（Assignat），也就是纸币，价值彻底
tanked in value. Food prices are still very high. People are blaming the middle classes, hoarders, speculators. Marat specifically talks of the bourgeoisie. Austrians in French dress, the papers call them. And of course, the ultimate Austrian in French dress is Marie Antoinette, right? Of course. The standard image now of Louis XVI is that he is a fat pig. I mean, that is literally what he's called. He's got a fat pig kind of in a load of swill, such chaotic and risible lack of tact.
暴跌。食品价格依然居高不下。人们在指责中产阶级、囤积居奇者、投机商。马拉特明确谈到了资产阶级。报纸称他们为“穿着法国服装的奥地利人”。当然，终极的“穿着法国服装的奥地利人”就是玛丽·安托瓦内特，对吧？当然。现在对路易十六的标准形象就是他是一头肥猪。我的意思是，字面意思上他就是这么被叫的。他就像一头肥猪呆在一堆泔水里，表现出一种如此混乱且荒谬的缺乏 tact（圆滑/分寸感）。
The Austrian Empress had died and he ordered his court into mourning, into official mourning, despite the fact that their two countries are at war. And of course people say, look at Mary Antoinette and they say, yeah, they call her the Austrian whore and they say she's probably passing secrets to the Austrians. And she is. I mean, this is the thing. Yeah, that is the amazing thing, isn't it? Well, and the things that are written about her by Hebert at this point are vituperative.
奥地利皇后去世了，而他命令他的宫廷进入哀悼期，进入官方哀悼期，尽管这两个国家正处于战争状态。当然人们看着玛丽·安托瓦内特说，看吧，他们叫她奥地利妓女，还说她可能在向奥地利人传递机密。而她也确实这么做了。我的意思就是这样。是的，这才是最惊人的地方，不是吗？嗯，埃贝尔在这个时候写关于她的那些东西，简直是恶毒至极。
He has this absolute fantasy of bringing her before the people. She has to make a public confession of all this. And then she is set to work sweeping the streets or as a cleaner in the Salpeteria Hospital, which is the place that beggars and prostitutes are sent to. He is fantasizing about a complete subversion of the social order as punishment for the corruption and crimes of the Queen and her fat useless husband. And this becomes increasingly widespread. So within about a month of the declaration of war, the people who basically have dragged
他有一种极端的幻想，要把她带到人民面前。她必须对这一切做出公开忏悔。然后她被派去扫大街，或者去萨尔佩特里耶医院（Salpêtrière Hospital）当清洁工，那是关押乞丐和妓女的地方。他幻想彻底颠覆社会秩序，以此作为对女王和她那个肥胖无用的丈夫的腐败与罪行的惩罚。这种情绪变得越来越普遍。因此，在宣战大约一个月内，那些基本上把法国
France into this war, the Girondins, that particular faction, Briceau's faction, they're already looking for scapegoats. It's their own fault, of course, they're already looking for scapegoats. It's their own fault, of course, but they're looking for scapegoats and they point the finger at the king and queen. So on the morning of the 23rd of May, Briso gets up in the assembly and he says, I can reveal an Austrian plot to destroy the revolution. The central agent is the queen. And he says, I have no evidence of this, but of course we all know that lack of evidence of a conspiracy is the ultimate proof. That's the fiendish cunning of it.
拖入这场战争的人——吉伦特派，那个特定的派别，布里索的派别——已经在寻找替罪羊了。这当然是他们自己的错，他们已经在寻找替罪羊了。这当然是他们自己的错，但他们正在寻找替罪羊，并将矛头指向了国王和王后。所以在5月23日的早晨，布里索在议会站起来说：我能揭露一个摧毁革命的奥地利阴谋。核心特工就是王后。然后他说：我对此没有任何证据，但当然我们都知道，缺乏阴谋的证据正是阴谋存在的终极证明。这就是它的恶毒狡猾之处。
That is the cunning. By this point, the panic has been given a further kind of turn on the ratchet because two days in on the 21st, Prussia had entered the war as part of a secret deal with Austria. So at this point, the French, who thought they would win within weeks this easy victory, are facing the two most militarily powerful Central European monarchies put together. In the assembly, they say, right, we're going to emergency session. Deputies are literally sleeping at their seats. It's kind of meeting constantly.
这就是狡猾之处。到了这个时候，由于两天后的21日普鲁士作为与奥地利秘密协议的一部分参战，这种恐慌情绪进一步升级。因此，此时本以为能在几周内赢得这场轻松胜利的法国人，正面临着中欧军事实力最强大的两个君主国的联手夹击。在议会里，他们说，好，我们要召开紧急会议。代表们甚至直接睡在座位上。会议基本上在不间断地进行。
Because you said before how the amazing thing throughout the French Revolution is that essentially everyone is shattered. No one's getting any sleep. Yeah. From this point onwards. I mean, if you think of the politics of it, I think you have to assume that the politics is happening constantly. I mean, around the clock at any given moment, at four o'clock in the morning, there are people in the assembly muttering in corners and somebody's making a speech that no one can listen to because everybody else is asleep. And as Lafayette shows, if you snooze you lose. Yes, exactly.
正如你之前所说，整个法国大革命期间最神奇的事情在于，本质上每个人都筋疲力尽。没有人能睡个好觉。是的。从这个时刻开始。我的意思是，如果你想想其中的政治运作，你必须假设政治活动一直在发生。我的意思是，夜以继日，在任何给定的时刻，在凌晨四点钟，议会里总有人在角落里低声细语，某人在发表一段根本没人听的演讲，因为其他所有人都睡着了。正如拉法耶特所展示的那样，打盹就会输。是的，完全正确。
I'm glad you admit that now, Tom. So Paris is lit up and it will be lit up at night for a lot of the rest of this story. Citizens are told burn candles in your windows because you will need to see the villains, the traitors, traders reading their attack. The assembly passes to emergency measures one is a crackdown on dissident priests trying to deport them from france and another is an appeal for tens of thousands of volunteers to come from the provinces to help defend the capital and louis And Louis disastrously vetoes both of them. Why, I can't quite explain why he would have such a lack of political sensitivity. I guess it's a last attempt to assert his authority, his role in the constitution.
汤姆，我很高兴你现在承认这一点。所以巴黎被灯火照亮，并且在接下来的大部分时间里，夜晚都将灯火通明。公民们被告知要在窗前点燃蜡烛，因为你们需要看清那些恶棍、叛徒，那些阅读攻击性言论的叛徒。议会通过了紧急措施：一项是打击异见神父，试图将他们驱逐出法国；另一项是呼吁数万名志愿者从各省赶来协助保卫首都。而路易
And it's a sign of just how frankly, how uncalculating, how thoughtless he is. He picks the wrong battles, doesn't he? Always picks the wrong battles. He picks the wrong battles and he seeds vital points of self-interest with a kind of wave of the hand. He does indeed. He's hopeless.
灾难性地对这两项措施都行使了否决权。为什么，我实在无法解释他为什么会如此缺乏政治敏感性。我猜这是他最后一次试图维护自己的权威、维护他在宪法中的角色。这也表明了他坦率地说有多么不经计算、多么轻率。他总是挑错对手，不是吗？总是挑错对手。他挑错了对手，却轻挥手袖，拱手让出了关乎自身切身利益的关键阵地。他确实如此。他没救了。
He is hopeless. So in reaction to that, the Girondins publish an open letter, it was actually drafted by Madame Rolland, who we talked about before, saying to the king, an open letter saying, if you don't change your mind, you will lose your throne. This is no time to retreat. She says, if you don't prove your loyalty to the revolution, local officials take violent measures and the angry people will add to them through its excesses. In other words, if you don't show yourself on our side, you are facing enormous, enormous problems. No king has ever been addressed publicly by his own ministers in such a way in French
他没救了。因此，作为对这一举动的反应，吉伦特派发表了一封公开信——这实际上是由我们之前谈到过的罗兰夫人起草的——对国王说，一封公开信写道：如果你不改变主意，你将失去你的王位。现在绝不是退缩的时候。她说，如果你不证明你对革命的忠诚，地方官员将采取暴力措施，愤怒的人民更会通过其过激行为火上浇油。换句话说，如果你不表明你站在我们这一边，你将面临巨大无比的问题。在法国历史上，还从未有哪位国王被自己的大臣以这种方式公开喊话。
history. Louis is aghast at this and two days later he sacks the Girondins ministry. He does have the power to do that in the constitution, but again, what a stupid thing to do. So he replaces them with kind of royalist loyalists. This provokes a massive, massive crisis. And after days of sort of tension on the 20th of June, you have one of the kind of landmark days of the revolution. What happens here is that the leaders of the Paris kind of neighborhoods,
路易对此震惊不已，两天后他解散了吉伦特派内阁。他在宪法中确实有权力这么做，但话说回来，这是多么愚蠢的做法。于是他用一群保王派忠实信徒取代了他们。这引发了一场巨大无比的危机。经过数日的紧张对峙，在6月20日，迎来了这场革命具有里程碑意义的日子之一。这里发生的事情是，巴黎各个街区（被称为“区”）的领导人们，组织了一场针对国王的大规模公众示威。我们已经经历过无数次公众示威了，对吧，汤姆？而且以后还会有更多。但这是其中最著名的一次之一。当时大约有25,000人，其中许多是女性。而这正是我们曾提过一两次、但以后会更频繁谈到的一群人——那就是无套裤汉（sans-culottes）。汤姆，我知道你会大谈特谈这个，因为你是个伟大的裤子历史学家。你热爱裤子、马裤以及所有这些生意。
the sections as they're called, they organize a huge public demonstration against the king. So we've had loads of public demonstrations, haven't we Tom? And there are many more to come. But this is one of the most famous ones. So there are about 25,000 people, a lot of them are women. And these are a group of people that we've referred to maybe once or twice, but we'll be talking about them much more often. And these are the sans-culottes. And Tom, I know you're going to be talking a lot about it because you're a great historian of trousers. You love trousers and britches and all that business.
汤姆·麦卡利斯特 我一向关注18世纪末的巴黎城市时尚。
Tom McAllister I'm all about urban Parisian fashion in the late 18th century. Jason Vale Oh, of course you are. So we'll be talking about their clothes next week. But for now, they're basically urban workers, not the very poorest. So a lot of them are actually quite skilled craftsmen and artisans, but they're very politicised, the sonculote. They're very populist. They're in favour of the revolution. They hate the monarchy.
杰森·维尔 哦，你当然关注。所以我们下周会聊聊他们的衣服。但就目前而言，他们基本上是城市工人，而不是最穷的那批人。所以其中很多人其实是相当熟练的工匠和手艺人，但无套裤汉们政治化程度非常高。他们非常民粹。他们赞成革命。他们痛恨君主制。
They want price controls. They're quite nationalistic, all of this kind of business. First of all, they invade the legislative assembly, which is in the Manège, in this riding school next to the Tuileries. Their spokesman is allowed in and he reads a petition and he says, you know, the people have awoken. We are the people and we have awoken. The King is betraying us.
他们想要价格管制。他们相当民族主义，诸如此类。首先，他们冲进了立法议会，议会当时位于杜伊勒利宫旁边的骑兵学校（Manège）。他们的发言人被允许进入并宣读了一份请愿书，他说，人民已经觉醒了。我们就是人民，我们已经觉醒了。国王在背叛我们。
If he fails in his duties, he no longer exists for the French people. And then they demand a right to basically march through the assembly. I mean, imagine a scene like this in the US Congress or it's very January the 6th actually. They want to march through the legislative assembly and the deputies basically give into them and say, fine. They have a military band playing songs, they're waving flags, they have a big tablet with the rights of man on the tablet. Unbelievable. So that's lovely if you're, you know, if you like that kind of thing, but they also have a calf's heart stuck on a pike with a sign that says heart of the aristocrats.
如果他未能履行职责，他对于法国人民来说就不复存在了。然后他们要求获得在议会中游行通过的权利。想象一下美国国会里出现这样的场景——这其实非常像1月6日事件。他们想要穿过立法议会游行，而代表们基本上向他们妥协了，说：好吧。他们有一支乐队在演奏歌曲，挥舞着旗帜，他们还拿着一块刻有人权宣言的大牌子。难以置信。所以如果你喜欢那种调调，这倒也挺美妙的，但他们还把一颗小牛的心脏插在长矛上，上面挂着一个牌子，写着“贵族的心”。
And basically when they walk past deputies who are more moderate, centrist, they shake their fists at them and wave this heart at them and shout abuse. Well, I mean, if there's one thing you can say about Centrist dads, they don't like calf's hearts stuck on a pike being waved in their faces, do they? No, they would hate that on the rest of politics, wouldn't they? They wouldn't approve of that, no. So the crowd goes to the assembly and then it turns its attention to the Tuileries Palace. There's this huge crush outside the palace.
基本上，当他们走过那些比较温和、中间派的议员时，他们会向对方挥舞拳头，把这个心脏在对方面前晃来晃去，并大声辱骂。嗯，我的意思很明显，如果你能对中间派老爸们说一句话的话，那就是他们不喜欢被插在长矛上的小牛心脏在他们脸前晃来晃去，对吧？不，他们在其他政治场合也会讨厌这一点的，对吧？他们是不会赞成这种事的，不会的。所以人群去了议会，接着把注意力转向了杜伊勒利宫。宫殿外挤满了人。
And actually what happens here is the guards's this huge crush outside the palace. And actually what happens here is the guards open the gates to prevent the crush. It's not that the crowd necessarily storm in, but they're basically allowed in. Then this giant crowd, or if you're Edmund Burke, you call it a mob, I suppose. A ravaging mob. They pour into the palace. They're heavily armed so a lot of them have muskets and pikes. Pikes become symbols of the Songkulotan of the revolution. And they're even dragging cannons with them. I mean, what they think they're going to do with these cannons, I don't know.
实际上这里发生的情况是，卫兵为了防止踩踏事故打开了大门。并不是说人群一定要强行冲进去，而是他们基本上被允许进去了。随后，这群庞大的人群——如果你是埃德蒙·伯克（Edmund Burke），你会称之为暴民——涌入了宫殿。他们武装精良，很多人带着火枪和长矛。长矛成为了无套裤汉和革命的象征。他们甚至还拖着大炮。我的意思是，他们带着这些大炮打算干什么，我可不知道。
Or indeed cannon. Indeed cannon. If you prefer to use the American style plural, Tom, we've discussed this. This will mean nothing to our listeners, but this is an ongoing saw behind the scenes of the rest of history. They get upstairs and there they find Louis the King and he's with a few of his kind of noble friends. And basically the crowd swarm into this kind of drawing room and they force him back into this bay window. And it really is an unbelievable moment. I mean, you think it's only what three years since since he was in gilded splendor at Versailles surrounded by people with massive wigs. And now he's standing in this bay window surrounded by representatives of the people.
或者说确实是大炮（cannon/cannons复数形式的幽默）。如果你更喜欢用美式复数形式的话，汤姆，我们讨论过这个。这对我们的听众来说毫无意义，但这正是《一切皆历史》幕后一直在持续的一个梗。他们上了楼，在那里找到了路易国王，他正和几个贵族朋友在一起。基本上，人群蜂拥进入这个客厅，把他的退路逼到了一个凸窗前。这真的是一个难以置信的时刻。我的意思是，你觉得距离他在凡尔赛宫金碧辉煌中被戴着大假发的人群环绕，仅仅过去了三年时间。而现在他正站在这个凸窗前，被人民的代表们团团包围。
But they haven't got a calf's heart. To be fair, they haven't brought it with them. So there is that. Yeah, there's pluses and minuses. All historians actually say at this moment, Louis does really quite well. So it's a bit Charles I on trial or something. He shows in this moment of great extremity, a kind of sang-fran at composure, because they are yelling abuse in his face. You're Monsieur Vito. You obviously don't want France to win the war.
不过他们没有带小牛的心脏。公平地说，他们没有把那玩意儿带在身上。所以总算还有点庆幸。是的，有得必有失。所有的历史学家实际上都说，在这个时刻，路易表现得相当不错。这有点像查理一世在接受审判之类的场景。他在这个极度危险的时刻，表现出了一种冷静和泰然自若（sang-froid），因为人群正在他脸前大喊大叫。你是维托先生。你显然不希望法国赢得战争。
You're not really the king of France. You're the king of the immigres. A butcher called Le Gendre is right up in his face and Le Gendre says, Monsieur, you must hear us, you're a villain. You've always deceived us, you deceive us still. Your measure is full that people are tired of this play acting. And the thing is Le Gendre is not wrong. Like much as sometimes listeners to the podcast have said, you know, like so many British writers, you tell the story from the perspective of the king and the aristos. You know, oh dear, the great unwashed have invaded my palace. What a terrible shame.
你根本不是真正的法国国王。你是流亡者的国王。一个名叫勒让德（Le Gendre）的屠夫凑到他脸前，勒让德说：先生，你必须听我们说，你是个恶棍。你一直在欺骗我们，现在还在欺骗我们。你的恶行已经满盈，人民对这种演戏已经厌倦了。问题是，勒让德并没有说错。尽管有时播客的听众会说，就像许多英国作家一样，你们总是从国王和贵族的角度来讲述故事。哦天哪，下等人侵入了我的宫殿。这太遗憾了。
But the thing is, Legendre is right. Louis has to see the revolution. He has been tricking them. So he does have right on his side to an extent. Anyway, Louis doesn't lose his cool. Somebody gives him a red bonnet, which is a symbol of the revolution. He puts it on. Somebody pushes a bottle into his hand, red bonnet, which is a symbol of the revolution. He puts it on. Somebody pushes a bottle into his hand, says, go on, drink a toast to the revolution.
但问题是，勒让德是对的。路易必须正视这场革命。他一直在欺骗他们。所以在某种程度上他确实占理。无论如何，路易没有失去冷静。有人递给他一顶红色卡佩尔帽（红平顶帽），那是革命的象征。他把它戴上了。有人把一个瓶子塞进他手里，红色的帽子，那是革命的象征。他把它戴上了。有人把一个瓶子塞进他手里，说：来吧，为革命干一杯。
Drink a toast to the people of Paris. And he does actually. He says, you know, here's to the people of Paris, here's to the nation. And because he's so calm, which is to his credit, actually, I mean, whatever you think of Louis XVI, he does show, I think, considerable courage at this point and he's polite to them. He never apologises for who he is, but he just says, you know, this isn't the time to discuss this, I understand where you're coming from, all this thing. He seems to be wearing them down, but then suddenly somebody starts shouting about the Queen and they batter down
为巴黎人民干一杯。而他真的照做了。他说，为了巴黎人民乾杯，为了国家乾杯。因为他如此冷静——这确实值得赞扬，不管你对路易十六怎么看，我认为他在此时表现出了相当大的勇气，而且他对他们很有礼貌。他从不为自己的身份道歉，他只是说，现在不是讨论这个的时候，我理解你们的立场，诸如此类的话。他似乎把他们说得有些消气了，但突然有人开始大喊大叫关于王后的事，他们砸开了大门，终于找到了玛丽·安托瓦内特。同样，对她也是这样。人们对她大喊大叫，而她缩在角落里，诸如此类。这种情况持续了好几个小时。我的意思是，他们就在那儿。这可不是20分钟的事。这大概是个持续两小时的活儿。真奇怪她没有被撕成碎片。
these doors and finally they locate Marie Antoinette. And again, the same thing with her. They're sort of shouting at her and she's cowering in the corner and all of this. And this goes on for a couple of hours. I mean, they're there. It's not like 20 minutes. This is probably a two hour job. It's amazing that she doesn't get torn to pieces.
你知道吗？我完全同意你的看法，汤姆。这对我来说在某种奇怪的程度是个谜。为什么，她是怎么活着逃过一劫的？我不知道她在干什么。因为你不可能在角落里缩上两个小时。嗯，显然你可以。你当然可以，我想。是的，因为她确实这么干了。
Do you know what? I completely agree with you, Tom. That's to me in a weird way, that's a bit of a puzzle. Why is, how does she escape alive? I don't know what she's doing. Cause you can't cower in a corner for two hours. Well, clearly you can. You can, I suppose. Yeah, because she does.
这太不可思议了。但实际上，最终一个代表团——议会派遣了无数代表团前来调解，最终他们设法说服人群散去，不要再纠缠他们。好了，你们已经表达了诉求，现在离开宫殿吧。因此到了那天晚上八点左右，最后一批无套裤汉被请出了宫殿，四周陷入了寂静。你知道的，你不需要成为这对王室夫妇的超级崇拜者，也会承认对他们来说，这一定是一个难以置信的创伤性和可怕的时刻。他们能够毫发无伤地逃过一劫，简直堪称奇迹。现在，法国人民实际上为此对他们产生了一点同情，因为开始有请愿书源源不断地涌入议会，上面有成千上万人的签名，其中包括巴黎人民，他们说那确实有点过分了，那不应该发生。王室夫妇应该受到更好的保护。不能让暴民强行闯入并骚扰他们。但感到最震惊的人，汤姆，却是你的一位伟大英雄。你视为革命中最杰出政治家的那个人。
I mean, it's improbable. But actually, eventually a delegation, the assembly sending numerous delegations to intercede and eventually they managed to persuade the crowd to disperse, to leave them alone. Okay, you've had your say, now clear out of the palace. So by about eight o'clock that evening, the last of the soncolotes ushered out of the palace and silence falls. And you know, you don't have to be a huge admirer of the royal couple to accept that this must have been an unbelievably traumatic and frightening moment for them. And the fact that they've escaped unscathed is something of a miracle. Now they do actually get a bit of sympathy from the people of France for this because there are petitions that start to come into the assembly signed by thousands of people, including the
18世纪末的加拉哈德（骑士）。是的。拉法耶特侯爵。拉法耶特侯爵。
people of Paris saying that was a bit much, that shouldn't have happened. The royal couple, they should be better guarded. You can't have mobs bursting in and harassing them. But the person who was most shocked, Tom, is a great hero of yours. The man who you regard as the outstanding statesman of the revolution. The Galahad of the late 18th century. Yeah. The Marquis de Lafayette. Marquis de Lafayette.
嗯，他不再是侯爵了，不是吗？不。拉法耶特。拉法耶特将军。在某些人看来是个头脑空空的政治侏儒，而在另一些人眼中。是个骑士。没错。拉法耶特侯爵当时不在法国的某支军队里指挥，也就是位于梅茨（Metz）的中央军。现在拉法耶特——他原本以为这场战争将是他重返巅峰的通行证——已经有点失去热情了，
Well, he's not the Marquis anymore, is he? No. Lafayette. General Lafayette. An empty headed political dwarf for some, for others. A Chevalier. Exactly. The Marquis de Lafayette has been off command in one of the armies of France, the army at the centre, which is in Metz. Now Lafayette, who thought by the way that the war was going to be his ticket back to the top, he has slightly lost enthusiasm,
不是吗，汤姆？因为四周后他向立法议会发了一条消息，说我实际上认为我们应该投降。我认为我们应该寻求和平。我们赢不了这场战争。这绝对是教科书级别的拉法耶特式行为。我也很高兴地向大家汇报，他一直在向奥地利人发送秘密信件，说——这简直表明拉法耶特毫无头脑。这表明他是一位外交大师。一位外交大师。他说，大家觉得暂停战争怎么样？天才。
hasn't he Tom? Because after four weeks he sends the Legislative Assembly a message and says I actually think we should surrender. I think we should see for peace. We're not going to win the war. Absolutely textbook Lafayette behavior there. He's also, I'm pleased to report, been sending secret letters to the Austrian saying, I mean, this just shows that Lafayette has no idea. It shows that he's a master diplomat. A master diplomat. He says, how do you fancy pausing the war? Genius.
为了让我能够回到巴黎。太棒了。重新确立控制权，然后我们可以在那之后考虑重新开战。这有什么不对的？显然奥地利人对这个主意并不热心。现在他对自己说，就像汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）梦中的英雄一样，他说：你知道吗？我大概就是尤利乌斯·恺撒。我要跨过卢比孔河，荣耀地返回巴黎，夺取控制权。所以在6月28日，也就是这起杜伊勒利宫事件几天后，谁应该抵达巴黎的立法议会呢？
To allow me to go back to Paris. Brilliant. To reassert control and then we can consider restarting the war after that. What's wrong with that? And obviously the Austrians are not keen on this idea. And now he says to himself, like the hero of Tom Holland's dreams, he says, do you know what? I probably am Julius Caesar. I will cross the Rubicon, return to Paris in glory, seize control. And so on the 28th of June, so just a few days after this Tuileries business, who should arrive in the Legislative Assembly in Paris,
那个时刻的英雄大步流星地走进来，正是拉法耶特。身穿制服。是的。佩剑，诸如此类。他把军队留在了——是的。佩剑，诸如此类。他把军队留在了前线，而他本人却来到了这里。他说：够了。关闭那些激进的俱乐部，关闭那些激进的报纸。
striding in the man of the hour, then Lafayette. In his uniform. Yeah. Sword, all that. He's left his army on Yeah. Sword, all that. He's left his army on the frontier and here he is. And he says, enough is enough. Close down the radical clubs, close down the radical papers.
我要让街头恢复秩序。我有军队的全力支持。时机已到。而立法议会的代表们对拉法耶特说：你的军队在哪里？所有支持你的部队都在哪里？难以置信的是，就像那个在巨大危机中会睡着的人一样，他竟然忘了把他们一起带过来。这非常能反映他那轻信的性格。他身边一个人都没带。许多代表对此感到震惊
I want order in the streets. I have the full backing of the army. The hour has come. And the deputies of the legislative assembly say to Lafayette, where is your army? Where are all the troops who support you? And unbelievably, rather like the man who would go to sleep in the middle of a huge crisis, he's neglected to bring them with him. That reflects very well on his trusting nature. He hasn't got any men with him. And a lot of the deputies are absolutely appalled by
至极，因为他们认为拉法耶特在背叛他们。我的意思是，其中一人，他曾经的崇拜者雅克·皮内（Jacques Pinet）。我曾以为拉法耶特是自由的热忱而热心的捍卫者，但现在我不得不面对现实，我心中感到恐惧和仇恨，因为我看到他是一个打着爱国主义旗号——你又看到了那个自负的借口——将我们引向深渊的叛徒。我的意思是，这就是许多代表所说的话。你又看到了那个自负的借口——将我们引向深渊的叛徒。这就是许多代表所说的话。而拉法耶特之所以没有把军队带来，
this because they think Lafayette is betraying them. I mean, one of them, a former admirer of his, Jacques Pinet. I believed Lafayette to be the ardent and zealous defender of liberty, but now I had to face the reality and I feel horror and hatred in my heart since I see him as a traitor, who in the guise of patriotism, there you have that conceit again, is leading us into an abyss. I mean, this is what a lot of the deputies say. you have that conceit again, is leading us into an abyss. And this is what a lot of the deputies say. And Lafayette, the reason he hasn't brought the army
是因为他认为自己只要去找国民自卫军就行了——当然，这支军队是他一手组建的——他将能够唤起他们向雅各宾派进军并夺取城市的控制权。结果这是一场彻头彻尾的灾难。当他气势汹汹地找到国民自卫军说：好，谁跟我干？你知道的，只有滚草飘过，一片尴尬的长久的沉默。难以置信的是，甚至连国王和王后都不支持拉法耶特。他们恨他。事实上，
is because he thinks he will just go to the National Guard, which of course he had been instrumental in setting up, and he will be able to rouse them to march on the Jacoma and take control of the city. And this is an absolute and utter disaster. Like when he pitches up to the National Guard and says, right, who's with me? You know, tumbleweed, long embarrassed silence. And unbelievably, even the King and Queen don't back Lafayette. They hate him. In fact,
他们正在向议会提供情报，说拉法耶特可能要搞政变。别听他的。他是个可怕的人。我们恨拉法耶特。但他们一直都恨他。他们确实如此。所以在这一幕极其可悲的场景中，拉法耶特的政变没有成功。于是他只好灰溜溜地回到阿尔萨斯的军队里。假装我们从来没说过这话。假装这一切从未发生过。永远不要再提它。因此，他自己的声誉已经彻底化为灰烬。当然，关于“爱国主义的伪装”这种说法，如果你本来就相信这一点，那么这就成了又一个证据，证明1789年所有那些革命者现在都已经被揭穿，不过是骗子和叛徒。
they're feeding information to the assembly saying Lafayette's probably going to do a coup. Don't listen to him. He's a terrible man. We hate Lafayette. But they've always hated him. They have. So Lafayette in this incredibly sort of pitiful scene, his coup doesn't work. So he goes back to Alsace to the army. Let's pretend that we'll never speak of this again. Let's pretend it's never happened. Let's never mention it. So his own reputation has been torched. But of course, this thing about the guys of patriotism, if you already believe in this, then this is just more proof that basically everybody who was a revolutionary in 1789 has now been exposed as a fraud and a traitor.
这进一步放大了这种偏执的情绪。现在我们进入了7月。距离战争爆发大概有两个多月了吧？政治权威几乎已经彻底崩溃。现在大多数代表都吓得不敢去立法议会了。在总共750名代表中，大概只有200人左右还在那里。他们都是硬核分子。所以所有的神父都走了，所有的贵族都走了。很显然他们早就走了。但即使是这个曾经在
So this further kind of amplifies this paranoid mood. So now we're into July. What are we like two and a bit months into the war and political authority has pretty much collapsed. Most deputies now are so frightened they don't turn up to the legislative assembly. There's probably only about 200 out of 750 who are still there. They're hardcore. So all the priests have gone, all the aristocrats have gone. Obviously they're long gone. But even this assembly, which was previously divided between
斐扬派（Foyon，应为Feuillants斐扬派）和各种雅各宾派之间分裂的议会，许多温和派甚至都不露面了。他们太害怕了。他们已经回了自己的庄园。因为他们被贴上了保王派的标签。他们被贴上了保王派的标签。完全正确。经济正处于崩溃的边缘。来自法国南部的报告称，那里发生了私刑处决。暴动、叛乱以及所有这类事情都在发生。许多激进分子说，好吧——我的意思是，他们并没有说错——这显然是一个不可持续的局面。奥地利人正坐在边境上，一片混乱。我们必须改弦易辙。
Foyon and various kinds of Jacobin, a lot of the moderates don't even turn up. They're too frightened. They've gone back to their estates. Because they're tied with the royalist brush. They're tied with the royalist brush. Exactly. The economy is in meltdown. There were reports coming in from the south of France that there are lynchings. There are riots, rebellions and all of this kind of thing. And a lot of radicals say, okay, I mean, they're not wrong. This is clearly an unsustainable situation. We've got the Austrians sitting on the frontier, total chaos. We have to change the record.
这种君主立宪制的实验已经彻底失败了，我们必须从头开始。这与克伦威尔时代英国的残缺议会（Rump Parliament）以及克伦威尔的政变有着惊人的相似之处。非常惊人。除了拉法耶特，我猜，他想成为那种角色——那个清除议会的克伦威尔。我的意思是，我知道你觉得我对拉法耶特太严厉了。不，不，这不是他政治生涯的高光时刻。我承认这一点。
This experiment in constitution monarchy has totally failed and we have to start again. The resemblance to the Rump Parliament in Cromwellian England and Cromwell's coup is quite striking. It's very striking. Except that Lafayette, I suppose, wanted to be that figure, the Cromwell, who clears out the assembly. I mean, I know you think I'm very harsh on Lafayette. No, no, it's not his best political moment. I accept that.
我认为拉法耶特的问题在于他实际上并不擅长政治。托马斯·杰斐逊曾这样评价他——托马斯·杰斐逊其实挺喜欢拉法耶特的——他说拉法耶特的巨大缺陷在于他有着对受欢迎程度的“犬儒般（实际为canine，应译为犬齿般/无休止的）的渴望”。我认为拉法耶特渴望被人喜欢。他没有那种钢铁般的意志，那种铁石心肠，没有冰冷的心中之刃。克伦威尔有，或者我们这个播客里也有。
I think the trouble with Lafayette is he's just actually not very good at politics. Thomas Jefferson said of him, he had a, Thomas Jefferson liked Lafayette. He said his great flaw was that he had a canine appetite for popularity. And I think Lafayette wants to be liked. He doesn't have the steel, the steel, this sort of steeliness, the cold blooded shard of ice in his heart. Yeah. The Cromwell has or, or present us on this podcast.
很好。但同时他也只是个糟糕的决策者。他总做出糟糕的判断。无论如何，在此时的俱乐部里，每个人都在说：对，我们需要废除君主立宪制，而我们实现这一目标的途径就是走上街头。我们要搞一场起义。他们对此毫不掩饰。这真的让我想起俄国革命以及1917年两次革命之间的那段时期，当时每个人都知道
Right. Very good. But also he's just a bad judge. He makes bad calls. Anyway, in the clubs at this point, everybody is saying, right, we need to scrap the constitution monarchy and the way we'll do this is on the streets. We'll have an insurrection. And they're completely open about it. It really does remind me of the Russian Revolution and the bit in between the two revolutions in 1917, where everybody knows the
对的。非常好。但同时他也只是个糟糕的法官。他做出了糟糕的判决。无论如何，当时在俱乐部里，每个人都说，对，我们需要废除君主立宪制，而实现这一目标的途径就是走上街头。我们要发动暴动。而且他们对此完全公开。这确实让我想起俄国革命，以及1917年两次革命之间的那个时期，当时每个人都知道
Bolsheviks are about to launch a coup, but people are kind of too paralyzed to do anything about it. Because the radical papers are absolutely saying, let's take to the streets, you know, kill, take prisoner, the royal family and have effectively a kind of popular dictatorship, dictatorship of the people, totally democratic system. The Girondins, the architects of the war previously seen as, you know, wanted to be seen as the champions of radicalism.
布尔什维克即将发动政变，但人们却因为某种瘫痪状态而无所作为。因为激进的报纸绝对在叫嚣着：走上街头，杀死、逮捕王室成员，并有效地建立一种类似人民独裁、人民专政的完全民主的系统。吉伦特派，这场战争的曾经被视为想要成为激进主义捍卫者的策划者们。
This leaves them in a bit of a mess. Do they go left and ally themselves with the sans-culottes? Do they kind of tack back to the centre and restore order? At first, Briceau's intention seems to be to go left. He launches a blazing attack on the king. He says we should probably set up a committee to see if the king has been guilty of treason. And yes, it is time to have a wider democracy and to think about, I mean, how old is the Constitution? A year? Yeah, if that. If that's not even that, but actually, yeah, this Constitution hasn't worked, let's
这让他们陷入了一片混乱。他们是该向左转，与无套裤汉结盟？还是稍微向中间靠拢并恢复秩序？起初，布里索的意图似乎是向左转。他发起了对国王的猛烈抨击。他说，我们或许应该成立一个委员会，调查国王是否有叛国罪。没错，现在是时候建立一个更广泛的民主制度了，想想看，宪法有多少年了？一年？对，如果有的话。如果连这个都算不上，但实际上，是的，这部宪法没有起作用，让我们
have a new Constitution. And then on the 11th of July, they have that proclamation that Jeremy Corbyn read at the beginning of this podcast. Yeah. The homeland is in danger and they appeal for volunteers. And so from this point onwards, you get three weeks in which thousands of people are arriving in Paris from the provinces. And these are members of the National Guard. One way to think about them might be as kind of paramilitary fighters.
制定一部新宪法。然后在7月11日，他们发布了杰里米·科尔宾在播客开头发布的那篇公告。对。祖国处于危急关头，他们呼吁志愿者挺身而出。因此，从这一刻起，接下来的三周里，成千上万的人从各省涌入巴黎。这些人是国民自卫队的成员。把他们看作某种准军事武装或许很合适。
They are not trained soldiers, a lot of them. They are volunteers. They are very keen on the revolution. Some of them have been involved in action already in their local provinces. For the Parisians, it's a bit of a shock. They have wildly different uniforms. They have great mustaches, a lot of them, because they've come from the countryside. And often they don't even speak French, do they? So the ones from the South might speak
其中许多人并不是受过训练的士兵。他们是志愿者。他们对革命满腔热情。他们当中有些人已经在各自的省份参与过战斗。对于巴黎人来说，这多少有些震撼。他们穿着千奇百怪的制服。许多人留着大胡子，因为他们是从乡下来的。而且他们往往连法语都不会说，对吧？所以来自南部的人可能会说
Occitan instead of French. Yeah, or Breton, or some of them speak German or Italian or whatever it might be. So these Federe, as they're called, a bit like Federati, Tom, in the Roman Empire. No, I think it comes from the Fete de la Federacion. Yeah. Because they're being summoned to celebrate that. But that sort of sense of them as auxiliaries, as auxiliaries who are kind of on their... Well, no, I'm not sure they are auxiliaries, because I think that they are the embodiment of La Patrie. Oh, of course they are.
欧西坦语而不是法语。对，或者布列塔尼语，还有一些人说德语、意大利语或诸如此类的语言。因此，这些被称为“联邦兵”（Federe）的人，有点像罗马帝国的联邦同盟军（Federati），汤姆。不，我认为它源自“联邦节”（Fete de la Federacion）。对。因为他们被召集来庆祝那个节日。但那种作为辅助部队的感觉，作为一种……嗯，不，我不确定他们是不是辅助部队，因为我认为他们是“祖国”（La Patrie）的化身。哦，当然是的。
Yes. Actually, as we will see, because the most famous of these contingents of Federer come from Marseilles, and they're singing a song that will be so associated with them that it will come to be called the Marseillaise, and singing a song that will be so associated with them that it will come to be called the Marseilles and we'll be looking at the circumstances of that in the next episode. Yes, we will indeed. That's to look forward to. So these people from Marseilles, in particular from the South, they are very radical. They're billeted at radical clubs. So they're sleeping on the floor of radical clubs. And don't forget the clubs are often going on all night. So they're literally listening to these speeches day in, day out, hour in, hour out. And a lot of them say,
是的。事实上，正如我们将看到的，因为这些联邦兵中最著名的一支来自马赛，他们唱着一首歌，这首歌将与他们紧密相连，以至于后来被称为《马赛曲》，唱着一首歌，这首歌将与他们紧密相连，以至于后来被称为马赛曲，我们将在下一集中探讨这背后的情况。是的，我们会的。这很令人期待。所以这些来自马赛的人，特别是来自南部的人，非常激进。他们被安置在激进俱乐部里。所以他们睡在地板上，在激进俱乐部的地板上。别忘了，这些俱乐部经常通宵达旦地活动。所以他们真的在日复一日、时时刻刻地聆听这些演讲。他们中的许多人说，
before we go out to fight the Austrians, we want to settle accounts with the traitors here in Paris, and in particular the king. We will not go and fight the Austrians until we have confronted the king. And David Andrus in his fantastic book on the terror, he makes the point that this does seem to be a genuinely bottom-up movement. So he says, Rosepia does not seem to have been directly involved in insurrection preparations. And he's, brilliant thing about Marat that although he had called in his pages for insurrections almost continuously since 1790, he allegedly took fright of the risks of a real one.
在我们出去与奥地利人作战之前，我们要先清算巴黎这里的叛徒，尤其是国王。在与国王对质之前，我们不会去和奥地利人打仗。大卫·安德鲁斯（David Andrus）在他那本关于恐怖统治的出色著作中指出，这似乎确实是一场自下而上的真正运动。因此他说，罗伯斯庇尔似乎没有直接参与暴动的筹备工作。关于马拉，有一个绝妙的事实：尽管自1790年以来，他几乎一直在报纸上号召起义，但他据称却对真正爆发起义的风险感到害怕。
Yeah. Sought protection from the Marseille Federer. I think it is bottom up. It absolutely is bottom up. Because at the end of July and the 31st of July, the first of the neighborhood groups in Paris, the sections, calls publicly for the overthrow of the king. For too long a despicable tyrant has played with our destinies. Let us all unite to declare the fall of this cruel king. Let's strike this colossus. Let us say with one accord, Louis XVI is no longer king of the French.
对。向马赛联邦兵寻求保护。我认为这是自下而上的。这绝对是自下而上的。因为在7月底，即7月31日，巴黎的第一个街区组织——各选区，公开呼吁推翻国王。卑鄙的暴君玩弄我们的命运已经太久了。让我们团结起来，宣告这个残酷国王的倒台。让我们给这个庞然大物致命一击。让我们异口同声地宣布：路易十六不再是法国人的国王。
And in the next few days, this is kind of distributed around the city and 39 more of the sections follow suit. They issue a joint statement and they say Louis is guilty of perjury, treason and conspiracy against the people. He has got to go. Okay, well let's take a break there and when we come back, we will be moving from Paris because we have bombshell news from the Germans. Exciting. So back soon.
在接下来的几天里，这在全城散发开来，又有39个选区效仿。他们发表了一份联合声明，称路易犯了伪证罪、叛国罪和阴谋反对人民罪。他必须下台。好吧，我们就在这里休息一下，回来后，我们将离开巴黎，因为我们收到了来自德国人的重磅消息。太激动人了。我们稍后回来。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, a splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's the restisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest is History and at the end of the first half, we promised
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐至死》（The Rest is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦绯闻，在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及抢先购买现场门票的福利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史至死》（The Rest is History），在上半场结束时，我们承诺过
you bombshell news from the Germans. Dominic, what is the bombshell news? So on the 3rd of August, news reaches Paris from the frontiers that the Prussian commander, the Duke of Brunswick, has issued an ultimatum to the city of Paris. Now this was actually written for him by a French émigré, the Marquis de Limon. Brunswick's manifesto, as it's called, says this, if you, the people of Paris, touch Louis and his family, we will wreak an exemplary and forever memorable vengeance on you. Paris will be destroyed and all revolutionaries
要带给你来自德国人的重磅消息。多米尼克，重磅消息是什么？所以在8月3日，前线传来消息称，普鲁士指挥官布伦瑞克公爵（Duke of Brunswick）向巴黎城发出了最后通牒。这实际上是由一位法国流亡贵族利蒙侯爵（Marquis de Limon）替他撰写的。布伦瑞克的这份宣言（正如人们所称的）这样写道：如果你——巴黎人民——胆敢动路易和他的家人一根汗毛，我们将对你们进行一场开创先例且永生难忘的报复。巴黎将被摧毁，所有的革命者
will be executed without mercy. And the point of this from the Prussian's perspective is they want to deter, they're very conscious that the royal family are effectively prisoners and they want to deter the revolutionaries from hurting them. But of course, what it does is it's instead of encouraging the moderates, it basically encourages the radicals to go all the way because they basically think we have nothing to lose. The Prussians have made it very clear they're going to fall on us like an avenging fury. Why don't we just, you know, might as well be hanged for a sheep as for a lamb. Why don't we just go all the way. And clearly the king must be in league with these people because they want
都将遭到毫不留情的处决。从普鲁士人的角度来看，他们的目的是进行威慑，他们非常清楚王室成员实际上已经成了阶下囚，他们希望以此威慑革命者不要伤害王室。但当然，这样做起到的效果是，它非但没有鼓励温和派，反而基本上鼓励了激进派破釜沉舟，因为他们基本上认为我们已经没有什么可失去的了。普鲁士人已经说得很清楚了，他们将如复仇女神般降临在我们头上。既然伸头是一刀，缩头也是一刀，我们为什么不干脆破釜沉舟呢。显然，国王一定和这些人勾结在一起，因为他们想要
to protect him. So we have to deal with him before the Prussians get to Paris. So in the next few days, they make their plans. As you said, Tom, it's a bottom up thing. There are people making plans all over Paris in section meetings and the clubs at the commune, which is the kind of municipal government of Paris. And the man who really more than anybody becomes the symbol of this, the man who coordinates a lot of this,
保护他。所以我们必须在普鲁士人到达巴黎之前处理掉他。因此，在接下来的几天里，他们开始制定计划。正如你所说，汤姆，这是一场自下而上的运动。巴黎各地的人们都在选区会议、俱乐部以及作为巴黎市政机构的公社（commune）里制定计划。而真正比任何人更能成为这场运动象征的人，协调了许多此类活动的人——
or so it seems, is a guy who had been the president of the Cordillier Club, the most radical of all the clubs. He's now a kind of junior sort of prosecutor's assistant at the commune. And this is a man we haven't really talked about yet, but is one of the great figures of the revolution, a man man called George Danton. Tommy, you a Danton fan? I am really. Ever since I saw the film in which Sherrod Depeydeux plays Danton. Yeah. It's a great film. That's a great Polish film.
或者看起来是这样的人，是一个曾担任科德利埃俱乐部（Cordillier Club，所有俱乐部中最激进的一个）主席的家伙。他现在是公社里的一名低级检察官助理。这就是我们还没怎么谈论过，但却是这场革命中伟大人物之一的人，一个名叫乔治·丹东（George Danton）的人。汤姆，你是丹东的粉丝吗？我真的是。自从我看过热拉尔·德帕迪约饰演丹东的那部电影以来。是的。那是一部很棒的电影。那是一部很棒的波兰电影。
Yeah. Basically about communism, wasn't it? It's about solidarity and communism. Yeah. Solidarity. Yeah. I saw that film when I was doing this for A-level and I thought it was absolutely brilliant. One of my favourite films ever since. And I've always loved the character of Danton. He's got a bit of the Trotsky about him, I think, because he's somebody who, spoiler alert, he ends up with a guillotine.
对。基本上是关于共产主义的，不是吗？那是关于团结和共产主义的。对。团结。对。我读A-level（高级水平考试）复习这段历史时看了那部电影，我觉得它太棒了。从那以后它就成了我最喜欢的电影之一。而且我一直很喜欢丹东这个角色。我觉得他身上有点托洛茨基的影子，因为他是一个这样的人——剧透一下——他最终上了断头台。
He goes from being the kind of Trotsky of the revolution. Well, he is the Trotsky of the revolution. That's sort of radical, organiser, belligerent and all that, but he ends up as a kind of martyr. Although slightly larger than Trotsky. Much larger. Trotsky is quite scrawny, isn't he? He is, but Danton's definitely not scrawny. Danton's not scrawny.
他从革命的某种托洛茨基……好吧，他就是革命的托洛茨基。那种激进的、组织者、好斗的等等，但他最终却成了一种烈士。虽然比托洛茨基体型大一些。大得多。托洛茨基很瘦削，不是吗？他是，但丹东绝对不瘦削。丹东一点也不瘦。
Danton's from the Champagne region, born in 1759. He's a Champagne socialist. He's a Champagne socialist, very good. He's 32 at this point, so a lot of these people are young. He's friends with Marat and Robespierre and Desmoulins, a lot of the characters, very good friends with them, a lot of these characters. And I think the thing that has always made him endearing to people who read about the Revolution or in Henry Mantel's case write about it, he's much more human than Robespierre. He likes his food, he likes his drink.
丹东来自香槟地区，出生于1759年。他是个“香槟社会主义者”。他是个香槟社会主义者，非常好。他当时32岁，所以这些人中有很多都很年轻。他和马拉、罗伯斯庇尔以及德穆兰是朋友，和许多风云人物都是好朋友，和很多这类人物关系密切。我认为，一直以来让他赢得读史之人的喜爱（或者在希拉里·曼特尔的书中）的原因是，他比罗伯斯庇尔更具人性。他喜欢美食，喜欢美酒。
He's very ugly, he's got the smallpox scars, but he's very charismatic, he's very theatrical. He's kind of a generous man as well. Yeah, he's a man with great appetites and human capacities, I would say. Slightly Falstaffian quality. He's greedy and he's very corrupt. So would it be ridiculous to say he's the Boris Johnson of the French Revolution? Kind of a large figure, untrustworthy, and a lot of people hate him, but equally he's a populist, isn't he? I mean, his populism is the point of Danton. So he is kind of coordinating all this. Tension on the streets is rising.
他长得很丑，有天花留下的疤痕，但他很有魅力，非常有戏剧性。他也是一个慷慨的人。是的，我觉得他是一个有着巨大食欲和人类容纳力的人。有点福斯塔夫式的气质。他很贪婪，而且非常腐败。那么，说他是法国革命中的鲍里斯·约翰逊，会不会太荒谬？有点像个大人物，不可信，很多人恨他，但同时他也是个民粹主义者，不是吗？我的意思是，他的民粹主义正是丹东的精髓所在。所以他在某种程度上协调了这一切。街头的紧张气氛正在加剧。
Why don't the Girondins do anything about it? After all, they're supposedly the people kind of in charge. And the interesting thing about this is while all this is're supposedly the people kind of in charge. And the interesting thing about this is while all this is brewing, what really is preoccupying a lot of them is Lafayette. They think Lafayette is going to take the opportunity to launch a coup. And actually, what that suggests to me, Tom, we've made the analogy a few times with Charles I and Oliver Cromwell, the Journeaux are slightly imprisoned, I think, by that analogy. Yeah. They're anxious about a Cromwell. And so they're missing the fact that actually the real threat to them is on the streets.
吉伦特派为什么对此什么都不做呢？毕竟，他们本该是掌权的人。而这件事有趣的地方在于，正当这一切在酝酿的时候，他们中许多人真正全神贯注关心的却是拉法耶特。他们认为拉法耶特会借机发动政变。实际上，汤姆，这向我表明——我们曾多次将查理一世和奥利弗·克伦威尔进行类比——吉伦特派在某种程度上被这种类比禁锢了。是的。他们对一个“克伦威尔”感到焦虑。因此他们忽略了这样一个事实：实际上对他们构成真正威胁的正在街头上。
And in fact, about this point, the gendarme, some of them start talking to the King who previously they've been slacking off left, right and center. And they sort of saying, would you like to have us back? You know, what should we, can we do a deal before the spiral is completely out of control? Now, when this comes out, this will be absolutely fatal for them that after all this they've been talking to the king. The king also knows something is coming. He's got messages from Lafayette saying I can get you out of Paris. You know, you are going to be in real trouble. But Marie Antoinette hates Lafayette so much that she's never going to do this. She says listen, if
事实上，大约在这个时候，宪兵（gendarme）中有些人开始与国王对话——此前他们左右摇摆、三心二意。他们有点像是说，你们还想让我们回来吗？你知道的，我们该怎么做，我们能在局势完全失控之前达成协议吗？现在，当这件事曝光时，对他们来说将是绝对致命的，因为在这一切发生之后，他们竟然一直在和国王谈话。国王也知道风雨欲来。他收到了拉法耶特的信，说我可以把你弄出巴黎。你知道的，你们会有大麻烦的。但玛丽·安托瓦内特对拉法耶特的恨意如此之深，以至于她绝不会这么做。她说，听着，如果我们
we get out of Paris now we'll be Lafayette's prisoners, she's never going to do this. She says, listen, if we get out of Paris now we'll be Lafayette's prisoners and that will definitely mean civil war. So for the time being, let's just stay put. So they're in the Tuileries Palace. He's agreed Louis with that, as you said, that catastrophic lack of judgment. He's agreed that his official bodyguard should be disbanded. Because that's his trump card. And he just whatever, yeah, let's get rid of it. Yeah, mad. I mean, he agreed to the disbanding his bodyguard at the same time that he vetoed those measures. Yeah. I mean, that's just the wrong way around. So the Tuileries is defended and it's maybe just worth stopping to say who by. There are about several
现在离开巴黎，我们就成了拉法耶特的阶下囚，她绝对不会这么做。她说，听着，如果我们现在离开巴黎，我们就成了拉法耶特的阶下囚，那绝对意味着内战。所以暂时我们还是按兵不动吧。于是他们留在了杜伊勒里宫。正如你所说，路易表现出了灾难性的判断力，他同意了这一点。他同意解散他的官方贴身卫队。因为那是他的王牌。而他不管怎样，好吧，让我们摆脱它吧。是的，太疯狂了。我的意思是，他同意解散贴身卫队的同时，却否决了那些措施。是的。我的意思是，这简直是本末倒置。所以杜伊勒里宫得到了防守，也许值得停下来看看是由谁防守。大约有几百名
hundred policemen. There are several hundred national guardsmen. There are noblemen, volunteers, but above all there are about a thousand members of the Swiss Guards who are widely hated within Paris. So those are the forces guarding the Tuileries. And now let's move to the night of the 9th and 10th of August because this is the moment of decision. This is the Great Showdown. And what happened that night, the chronology is incredibly confused and obscured by layers of gossip and rumour and mythology and propaganda. But let's start at the city hall, the Hôtel de Ville. Representatives of the Paris sections
警察。有几百名国民自卫队员。有贵族、志愿者，但最重要的是，大约有一千名瑞士卫队（Swiss Guards）成员，他们在巴黎内部广受痛恨。这就是保卫杜伊勒里宫的兵力。现在让我们转向8月9日至10日的夜晚，因为这是决定的时刻。这是终极大对决。那天晚上发生了什么，时间顺序极其混乱，被一层又一层的小道消息、谣言、神话和宣传所掩盖。但让我们从市政厅（Hôtel de Ville）开始。巴黎各选区的代表
burst into the Hôtel de Ville overnight and they say, we're dissolving the commune, the government of Paris, and we're setting up our own insurrectionary commune. And among its supporters are people like your Rob Spiers, your Danton, the kind of radical spokesman, journalists, and whatnot. And they say, the time has come, the insurrection, the second French revolution effectively, has begun. And they start ringing the toxin, the bells in the nearby Cordillier church. That is the signal to the rest of the city.
连夜闯入市政厅，他们说，我们正在解散公社，即巴黎政府，我们要成立我们自己的起义公社。其支持者中包括罗伯斯庇尔、丹东这样的人，以及激进的发言人、记者之类的人物。他们说，时机已到，起义，实际上可以说是第二场法国革命，已经开始了。他们开始敲响警钟，即附近科德利埃教堂的钟声。那是给全城其他地方的信号。
At around about 4.30 in the morning, they get the commander of the guards at the Tuileries, who's a guy called the Marquis de Monda. They summon him to the Hôtel de Ville. When he arrives, Danton rants and raves at him and says, you're a traitor, you're a conspirator, all this stuff, and orders him to be taken away to prison, which he is, and on the way somebody from the commune, we don't know who, shoots him in the head and kills him. And in his place, they say that the commander of the National Guard now for
大约在凌晨4点30分左右，他们找到了杜伊勒里宫卫队的指挥官，一个名叫蒙达侯爵（Marquis de Monda）的家伙。他们把他传唤到市政厅。他一到，丹东就对他大发雷霆，说你是个叛徒，你是个阴谋家，诸如此类的话，并下令把他带走关进监狱，他确实被带走了，而在路上，公社里不知哪个人（我们不知道是谁）朝他的头部开枪把他打死了。取而代之的是，他们宣布现在巴黎国民自卫队的指挥官
Paris is this guy who's a sonculote. He's a brewer called sonterre. He is a real bruiser. He is a kind of revolutionary hard man. So he's now in charge of the National Guard. By now, dawn breaking, there are loads of church bells ringing across Paris from onto the 10th of August now. There are tons of people in the streets, National Guardsmen and a lot of these Federer,
是一个无套裤汉。他是一个名叫桑泰尔（Sonterre）的酿酒师。他是个真正的恶霸。他是个不折不扣的革命硬汉。所以他现在负责国民自卫队。此时，黎明破晓，巴黎各地响起了无数的教堂钟声——现在已经是8月10日了。街上有大量的人，国民自卫队员以及许多联邦兵——
these the people from Marseille and from Lyon and Brittany and elsewhere, and they are armed to the teeth and gagging for a fight. They have weapons, they've stolen from the royal arsenal. There are loads of people rallied by the sections who have huge pikes and they all advance towards the Tuileries Palace. They arrive at the Tuileries and they find the defenders are drawn up as if preparing to resist a siege. It's very like the fall of the Bastille because remember the fall of the Bastille, the thing didn't start straight away. There's a kind of standoff where the insurgents are saying, come on, join us. This happens again. And actually at this point, some of the National Guardsmen supposedly guarding the Tuileries
这些来自马赛、里昂、布列塔尼和其他地方的人，他们武装到牙齿，渴望一战。他们拥有从皇家军械库偷来的武器。有大量由各选区动员起来的人手持巨大的长矛，他们全部向杜伊勒里宫推进。他们到达杜伊勒里宫，发现防守方已经列阵，仿佛准备抵御围攻。这非常像攻占巴士底狱，因为还记得攻占巴士底狱时，事情并没有马上开始。那是一种对峙状态，起义者在喊：来吧，加入我们。这再次发生了。事实上，此时据称保卫杜伊勒里宫的一些国民自卫队员
swap sides and go to join their Confederates among the kind of radical group. So that's happening outside. What about inside? So inside Louis and Marie Antoinette have been up for hours and are very conscious that this could well be the last day of their lives. Louis went down early to the courtyard to review the guards. The Swiss guard who were very loyal to him applaud him but a lot of the National Guardsmen either are silent and some of them actually shout abuse at him down with the traitor and this kind of thing. Marie Antoinette to her credit, you know, everyone thinks of Marie Antoinette as this
倒戈了，加入了激进派阵营中的联邦兵。外面的情况就是这样。里面呢？里面路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特已经醒了几个小时了，他们非常清楚这很可能是他们生命的最后一天。路易很早就下到庭院去检阅卫队。对效忠于他的瑞士卫队为他鼓掌，但许多国民自卫队员要么保持沉默，其中一些人甚至对他大喊侮辱性言论，比如“打倒叛徒”之类的话。玛丽·安托瓦内特值得称赞的是，你知道的，每个人都认为玛丽·安托瓦内特是那种
sort of simpering airhead at the Pitti Triennale pretending to be a milkmaid, but she's quite Theodora at this point, isn't she, Tom? I mean, she's been very tough throughout this. Yeah. Too tough, one might say. Yes. Because she, she grabs a pistol from an officer's belt and she gives it to Louis and says, now is the time to show who you are. I admire her for that. I think that is, well, it's impressive and yet also-
在皮蒂三年展上假装挤奶的女娇娃，但此刻她简直像狄奥多拉（Theodora）一样，不是吗，汤姆？我的意思是，她自始至终都非常坚强。是的。有人可能会说，太坚强了。是的。因为她从一个军官的腰带里抢下一把手枪，把它交给路易，并说：现在是展现你是谁的时候了。我为此很佩服她。我认为这——好吧，这令人印象深刻，但同时——
She's a fighter, not a quitter. She's the Peter Mantle son of the French revolution. A fighter, but not a quitter. You know, the people of Hartnip all would love her. But actually you could say if he'd followed her advice, I think he had died that day. He'd undoubtedly have died. But maybe that would have been a better way to go than... It would have been a brilliant way to go. I mean, he would have been a complete martyr. People would have said, imagine the biographers at the 16th. At the end, he found his courage. Yeah. Rather than going rather tamely to the slaughter.
她是个斗士，不是逃兵。她简直是法国革命中的彼得·曼特尔（Peter Mantle）之子。是个斗士，但不是逃兵。你知道的，哈特尼普（Hartnip）的人民会爱死她的。但实际上你可以说，如果他听从了她的建议，我想他那天就已经死了。他毫无疑问会死。但也许那会是一种比……更好的结局。那会是一个辉煌的结局。我的意思是，他会成为一个彻头彻尾的烈士。人们会说，想象一下十六世的传记作者怎么写。到最后，他找到了他的勇气。而不是像只待宰的羔羊般顺从地走向终点。
Yes. He ends up doing. He hesitates and he says to a municipal official, a guy called Rødre, what do you think I should do? And this guy Rødre says, I think you'd be mad to try and fight. The whole city hates you. The only way to save your family is basically to throw yourself on the mercy of the assembly.
是的。他最终做出的选择是犹豫不决。他问一个市政官员，一个叫勒德雷（Rødre）的家伙：“你觉得我该怎么做？”这个叫勒德雷的家伙说：“我觉得你要是试图反抗就太疯了。全城都恨你。拯救你家人的唯一方法，基本上就是向议会投降并听凭其发落。”
Take them to the assembly, throw yourself on their mercy. And he says, yeah, actually on reflection, I think you're probably right. I think that is better than the standing and fighting idea. So he takes his family, that's Marion Antoinette, their children, his sister Elizabeth, and they go through the gardens with the military escort to the riding school, the Manage, where the assembly is obviously permanently meeting. He's very calm, Louis. He says to Rudra, all he says is they walk through the gardens. The leaves are falling early this year. Is that a metaphor? That's the kind of quality of a Baudelaire poem and it's cryptic menace. Yeah. Or is it the words of a fool who's just commenting on the gardens?
带他们去议会，听凭他们的仁慈发落。路易说：“好吧，仔细想想，我觉得你可能是对的。我觉得这比坚守抵抗的想法要好。”于是他带着家人——也就是玛丽·安托瓦内特、他们的孩子、他的妹妹伊丽莎白——在军事护送下穿过花园，来到议会常驻的骑术学校（Manage）。路易非常冷静。他对勒德雷说，当他们走过花园时，他只说了一句：“今年的树叶落得真早。”这算是一个隐喻吗？这有点像波德莱尔诗歌的质感，带着隐秘的威胁感。是的，还是说这只是一个对花园随口评论的傻瓜的话？
Well, I mean, talking of a fool, he doesn't leave orders for the Swiss Guards, does he? No, no, but how could he though? I mean, how'd he doesn't know what's going to happen? He could have said surrender. Yeah, but Marat Manet probably is saying, fight on, fight to the last. Exactly. Anyway, they arrive in the legislative assembly. And it's a slightly awkward scene because he's not allowed constitutionally to be present in debates. So basically, he and his family are locked in the reporter's box behind a grill in this kind of cubby hole and there they wait and they start to hear gunshots, gunfire coming from the palace because what's happened at the palace is that the attackers have lost patience with the standoff. Some of the Federae from Marseille have started to force their way into the inner courtyard. There's a generally very chaotic scene, a bit of a scrum, and some of the Swiss
好吧，说到傻瓜，他没有给瑞士卫队留下撤退的命令，对吧？没有，没有，但他能怎么做呢？我的意思是，他怎么会知道接下来会发生什么？他本可以下令投降。是的，但玛丽·安托瓦内特大概在说“战斗到底，战至最后”。确实如此。不管怎样，他们抵达了立法议会。这是一个略显尴尬的场面，因为根据宪法规定，他不得出席辩论。因此，基本上他和他的家人被锁在栅栏后面的记者席里，在这个类似小隔间的空间里等待，他们开始听到从宫殿方向传来的枪声。因为宫殿里发生的事情是，攻击者对对峙失去了耐心。一些来自马赛的联邦兵开始强行闯入内庭。现场通常非常混乱，一片混战，一些瑞士
guards start shooting. Now some accounts suggest that actually the Swiss guard are shooting at some of their own men, stop them deserting. It's impossible to be sure. As soon as the shots ring out, it is very like the Bastille, the crowd, the kind of insurrectionists say, oh my God, they're doing it again. They've let us into the inner courtyard. It's a trap. And at that point they all pile in, they rush forward. The Swiss Guard just starts shooting indiscriminately. Hundreds of people are killed in this crossfire. Louis can hear all this from the assembly and he sends a message to the Swiss Guard, stop shooting, stop firing, but the messenger can't get through the chaos or the message isn't properly delivered, it's not clear what happened. Outside the palace, the streets have gone berserk. People
卫队开始开枪。现在有些说法表明，实际上瑞士卫队是在向他们自己人开枪，以阻止他们逃跑。这无法确定。枪声一响，就非常像巴士底狱事件，人群、起义者大喊：“天哪，他们又来了。他们把我们放进了内庭。这是一个陷阱。”就在那时，他们一拥而上，向前冲去。瑞士卫队开始盲目开枪。数百人在这种交火中丧生。路易在议会里听到了这一切，他向瑞士卫队发出了停止射击的讯息，但传令兵无法穿过混乱的人群，或者讯息没有正确传达，具体发生了什么并不清楚。宫殿外面的街道已经彻底陷入疯狂。人们
are shouting and screaming, the Swiss Guard are massacring our people, our people have been tricked, it's a plot by the king, all of this kind of stuff. Sontair, this hard man sends in a whole load of more National Guard who are kind of mad. Sonterre, this hard man, sends in a whole load of more national guards who are kind of maddened with rage. And then what happens is complete and utter bedlam. The Swiss guards shooting wild into the crowd, the crowd forcing them back into the palace, up the stairs, through the halls. And then you have this scene, you know, which is your kind of classic French revolution stereotypical scene of a kind of mob surging through the palace, gunfire, stuff being smashed up. They've started to set fire to the building. They also, in this chaos, they find boxes and piles of letters.
在大喊大叫、尖叫：“瑞士卫队在屠杀我们的人民，我们的人民被骗了，这是国王的阴谋”，诸如此类的话。这个恶汉桑泰尔派去了大批被愤怒冲昏头脑的国民自卫队。桑泰尔这个恶汉，派去了大批被愤怒激怒的国民自卫队。然后发生的事情是彻底的混乱。瑞士卫队向人群疯狂开枪，人群将他们逼回宫殿内，顺着楼梯，穿过大厅。然后你就会看到这样一个场景，你知道的，这是法国大革命中那种经典、模式化的场景：暴民汹涌穿过宫殿，枪声四起，东西被砸碎。他们开始放火烧建筑。在混乱中，他们还发现了箱子和成堆的信件。
Oh, yeah. See, why didn't they burn that before they went mad? Mad. I mean, especially if you have been conspiring against your people, definitely destroy the evidence. That's the lesson of history. So they find all these letters to and from the royal family. That's going to be a disaster for them in the long run. Now, when they find Swiss guards, when they catch up with them, they just kill them. And there's an incredibly, incredibly bloody scene. So the Swiss guard managed to make it out of the palace. They get into the Place de la Concorde. At that point they run into another crowd. Some of them are literally torn to pieces.
哦，是的。你看，他们为什么在发疯之前不烧掉这些？太疯狂了。我的意思是，特别是如果你一直在密谋反对你的人民，绝对应该销毁证据。这就是历史教训。所以他们找到了所有写给王室以及王室写出的信件。从长远来看，这将会是他们的灾难。现在，当他们找到瑞士卫队，当他们追上他们时，他们直接杀了他们。这是一个极其、极其血腥的场景。因此，瑞士卫队设法逃出了宫殿。他们进入了协和广场（Place de la Concorde）。就在那时，他们遇到了另一群人。其中一些人简直被撕成了碎片。
They presume it's not the Place de la Concorde at that point. At this point, no, it's what's, no, I don't think it is. Others start to tear off their uniforms. They won't be, they have these distinctive red uniforms. They tear them off in an attempt to disguise themselves and run into the streets. And there they are being, you know, it is like something from a sort of nightmarish Hollywood film. They are being pursued through the streets, kind of down alleys and whatnot by small groups of people who if they catch them will stone them to death, club them to death, stab them. You know, it's unbridled bloodshed.
他们推测那时还不是协和广场吧。此时，不，不是那样的，我觉得不是。其他人开始扯下他们的制服。他们不想……他们穿着这些标志性的红色制服。他们把制服扯下来，企图伪装自己并逃进街道。在那里他们被……（你知道的，这就像某种噩梦般的 好莱坞电影中的情节）他们被一小群人穿过街道、沿着小巷等等进行追捕，如果被抓住就会被用石头砸死、用棍棒打死、被刺死。你知道的，这是无法无天的血腥屠杀。
And there are these accounts, some people would say they are from counter-revolutionary or Anglo-Saxon sources. Indeed, they would. That the Swiss Guard are hideously mutilated, women strip the bodies, they loot the bodies. And I quote, this is Simon Sharma, mutilators hacked off limbs and scissored out genitals and stuffed them into gaping mouths or fed them to the bodies. And I quote, this is Simon Schama, mutilators hacked off limbs and scissored out genitals and stuffed them into gaping mouths or fed them to the dogs. What was left was thrown on bonfires, one of which spread to the palace itself and bits and pieces of the Swiss guards are then basically collected up and thrown into lime pits. Now some people
有这样一些记载，有些人会说它们来自反革命或盎格鲁-撒克逊的来源。的确如此。说瑞士卫队遭到可怕的肢解，妇女剥去尸体的衣服，劫掠尸体。我引述一下，这是西蒙·沙玛（Simon Schama）的话：“肢解者砍下四肢，用剪刀剪下生殖器，塞进他们大张的嘴里，或者喂给狗吃。”我引述一下，这是西蒙·沙玛的话：“肢解者砍下四肢，用剪刀剪下生殖器，塞进他们大张的嘴里，或者喂给狗吃。”剩下的东西被扔进篝火中，其中一处火势蔓延到了宫殿本身，瑞士卫队的残肢断臂随后基本被收集起来，扔进了石灰坑。现在有些人
will say this is just Edmund Burke reheated. This is kind of anti-revolutionary propaganda. But we have a very well-known eyewitness who saw all this. You've already mentioned seeing it, haven't we, in an episode before? In an episode before, a fellow from Corsica called Napoleone Buonaparte. And Napoleon is there and Napoleon said later, never have the piles of dead bodies on any of my battlefields affected me as much as the killing of dead bodies on any of my battlefields affected me as much as the killing of the Swiss. Hatred was in people's hearts and could be seen on their faces.
会说这只是埃德蒙·伯克（Edmund Burke）的老调重弹。这是某种反革命宣传。但我们有一个非常著名的目击者，他亲眼目睹了这一切。我们在之前的某一集中不是已经提到过目击者了吗？在之前的某一集中，一个来自科西嘉的家伙，名叫拿破仑·波拿巴（Napoleone Buonaparte）。拿破仑就在现场，拿破仑后来回忆说：“我任何战场上堆积如山的死尸，都没有像看到杀死瑞士卫队那样深深震撼我。仇恨充盈在人们心中，写在他们的脸上。”
I saw even quite well-dressed women commit the most extreme indecencies on the bodies of the Swiss guards. I mean, I think if this happens, the reason it does is because the mass of the people think that the Swiss guard has been trying to trick and trap them and have been treacherous. And this theme that the people who die in this confrontation have been the victims of royal treachery is something that will blaze across Paris and ultimately across France over the next months and years. Absolutely it is. So the way this is remembered in the next few months in Paris and in France, as you absolutely rightly say Tom, is not, oh my gosh, what a horrible massacre of the Swiss Guard.
“我甚至看到一些衣着光鲜的妇女在瑞士卫队的尸体上做出极其不体面的行为。”我的意思是，如果发生这种情况，原因就在于广大民众认为瑞士卫队一直试图欺骗和陷害他们，而且极其背信弃义。这种在冲突中死去的人是王室背叛的受害者的主题，将在接下来的几个月甚至几年里在巴黎乃至全法国熊熊燃烧。绝对是这样的。所以，正如你绝对正确地说的那样，汤姆，在接下来的几个月里，巴黎和法国对这件事的记忆并不是：天哪，对瑞士卫队的屠杀多么可怕。
It is, oh my gosh, what a horrible massacre by the Swiss Guard shooting on the crowd who were only there to show their, you know, exercise their rights as Frenchmen. They're evil, they're treacherous and even more evil and even more treacherous is the Royal couple who gave orders for them to do this. Yes, exactly. Because everybody assumes Louis and Marie Antoinette were behind all this. They'd planned all this with their partners in what they're now calling the Austrian committee, which is this sort of shadowy conspiracy that they think is controlling everything. And the weird thing about that Austrian committee is
而是：天哪，瑞士卫队对向人群开枪的屠杀多么可怕，而人群当时只是去展示他们的……你知道的，行使他们作为法国人的权利。他们是邪恶的、背信弃义的，而下令让他们这样做的王室夫妇则更加邪恶、更加背信弃义。是的，绝对如此。因为每个人都认为路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特是这一切的幕后黑手。他们和他们在他们现在称之为“奥地利委员会”（Austrian committee）中的伙伴一起策划了这一切，这是一个他们认为控制着一切的暗中阴谋。而关于那个奥地利委员会诡异的一点是——
it does kind of exist, doesn't it? I mean, you can be paranoid, but you can also be right. So anyway, in the assembly, Louis and the deputies have been listening with horror So anyway, in the assembly, Louis and the deputies have been listening with horror to hours and hours of gunfire and screaming and slaughter and all of this. And it's very obvious, I think, to the deputies that the constitutional monarchy is now totally finished. There's no way they can just say, well, they will draw a veil over this. Whatever. Move on. So that afternoon, the gendarme pass a resolution to have Louis suspended from office and they agree, okay fine we need a whole new system. We will call a national convention and it will be much
它确实某种程度上存在，不是吗？我的意思是，你可以被害妄想，但你也可以是正确的。总之，在议会里，路易和代表们怀着惊恐的心情——总之，在议会里，路易和代表们怀着惊恐的心情听着几个小时又几个小时的枪声、尖叫声、屠杀和这一切。我认为代表们非常清楚，君主立宪制现在彻底完结了。他们绝不可能只是说，好吧，我们会对此掩面不提。管他呢。继续前进。因此那天下午，国民议会通过了一项决议，暂停路易的职务，他们同意，好吧，我们需要一个全新的系统。我们将召开国民公会（National Convention），它将更加民主。它实际上将成为当时世界上最具民主性的议会。每一个有工作、年龄超过21岁且不是仆人的男子。
more democratic. It will actually be the most democratic assembly at that point in the world. Every single man who has a job, who is over the age of 21 and who is not a servant. But not women. But not women. So in the meantime, before the National Convention can meet, they have a basically provisional government and executive council and that has Girondins ministers. So they will be running France. And meanwhile, the royal family are taken away to the temple prison, which is a kind of medieval fortress. And they are now basically prisoners of the state. So the politics in this moment,
但没有女性。但没有女性。因此，与此同时，在国民公会召开之前，他们有了一个基本上属于临时政府和执行委员会的机构，其中包含吉伦特派的部长。所以他们将管理法国。与此同时，王室成员被带到圣殿监狱（Temple prison），这是一个中世纪的堡垒。他们现在基本上成了国家阶下囚。所以此刻的政治局势，
the politics of France has decisively shifted. The moderates, the foils, remember them? Yep. They're totally out of it now. They're finished. Bernabe and all that. Bernabe, they're gone. They've either left Paris already or those who are still in the assembly say, okay, there's no point backing the king. There's no point being a moderate. The circumstances have changed. We're all Jacobin now. Does the correspondence come out at this point?
法国的政治发生了决定性的转变。温和派，那些“顶梁柱”（feuillants），还记得他们吗？对。他们现在彻底出局了。他们完蛋了。巴纳夫（Barnave）和诸如此类的人。巴纳夫，他们走了。他们要么已经离开巴黎，要么那些还留在议会里的人说，好吧，支持国王已经没有意义了。做个温和派已经没有意义了。局势变了。我们现在全都是雅各宾派了。信件在这个时候曝光了吗？
Yes. So at this point, of course, people find... So what they find is that they weren't necessarily wrong about Louis. He was totally untrustworthy. He was corresponding with his brothers in the Rhineland. He was sending public funds to friends of his in the Rhineland emigres. He was even using public money to subsidize counter-revolutionary newspapers. So Louis is finished. Louis is done. Also finished, Lafayette. A week after the insurrection, Lafayette tries to rally his troops to the old constitutional monarchy. They mutiny. constitutional monarchy, they mutiny. Lafayette realizes he's probably for the chop. He deserts, he crosses the border, he gives himself up to the Austrians, they put him under arrest and Lafayette will spend the next five years in prison. And obviously the revolutionists
是的。所以在这个时候，当然，人们发现……所以他们发现他们对路易的看法不一定错。他完全不可信。他一直在与他在莱茵兰的兄弟们通信。他一直在把公共资金寄给他在莱茵兰流亡的朋友。他甚至一直在用公款资助反革命报纸。所以路易完蛋了。路易彻底完了。同样完结的还有拉法耶特。起义发生一周后，拉法耶特试图召集他的军队支持旧的君主立宪制。他们哗变了。君主立宪制，他们哗变了。拉法耶特意识到自己可能要大难临头了。他叛逃了，穿过边境，向奥地利人投降，奥地利人将他逮捕，拉法耶特将在监狱里度过接下来的五年。显然，革命者
can't punish him, but they take his wax work from Philip Curtis's wax museum and they cut his head off of the wax works, symbolic blow. They also confiscate his property. They do. And actually very nobly in due course when he's invited back by the convention, so long after the terror and everything. Yeah. He refuses to go back because he's not going to swear allegiance to a Republic dominated by Napoleon. So I think that shows him a manner principle. I just can't put that on the record. I mean, I'm just saying. Yeah. So I guess the question is like, I mean, don't forget they're still fighting a war. So who's going to fill the political vacuum? Well, on paper is the Girondins. The Girondins are in charge of the legislative assembly and they're able in the next few days to have
无法惩罚他，但他们拿走了菲利普·柯蒂斯（Philip Curtis）蜡像馆里的他的蜡像，并砍掉了蜡像的头，这是一种象征性的打击。他们还没收了他的财产。确实如此。事实上，在适当的时候，当他被国民公会邀请回来时——那是恐怖统治结束很久之后。是的。他拒绝回去，因为他不会向一个由拿破仑主导的共和国效忠。所以我认为这展现了他是有原则的人。我只是不能把这个记录在案。我的意思是，我只是说说。是的。所以我想问题是，别忘了他们还在打仗。那么谁来填补政治真空呢？嗯，纸面上是吉伦特派。吉伦特派掌控着立法议会，他们在接下来的几天里能够通过
a flurry of laws, like, you know, your revolutionary wish list. All the last vestiges of feudalism gone, emigre property seized, all religious houses in France, convents, monasteries, whatever, shut down. Priests who haven't sworn the oath to the constitution will be deported. Even if you have sworn the oath to the constitution, you're banned from wearing clerical clothes in public and, interestingly, the most liberal divorce laws in Europe. So here is, as it were, your progressive side, I guess, stole this, Tom. But if you think this means that the zhumedan are really in charge, you're mistaken because actually, the reality is total and
一连串的法律，比如，你知道的，你们的革命心愿单。封建主义的所有最后残余都消失了，流亡者的财产被没收，法国所有的宗教修会、女修道院、男修道院无论什么都被关闭。没有宣誓效忠宪法的神职人员将被驱逐出境。即使你宣誓效忠了宪法，你也禁止在公共场合穿神职人员服装，而且有趣的是，拥有欧洲最自由的离婚法。所以，这就是所谓的你们的进步一面，我想，偷了这个梗，汤姆。但如果你认为这意味着吉伦特派真的在掌权，那你就大错特错了，因为实际上，现实是彻底的、
utter chaos. There's this insurrectionary commune, there are the sections, there are the clubs. No one really knows who is, since the constitution has collapsed, no one knows who's actually running the city. The only person who really seems vaguely in charge is Danton. Danton becomes Minister of Justice. He recognizes that people want vengeance. He agrees to set up a revolutionary tribunal that has the first show trials at this point of royalists. So Tom, you talked about the guillotine, that brilliant episode on the guillotine. We have our first political execution with the guillotine on the 21st of August, so 11 days after the
绝对的混乱。这里有起义公社、有选区、有俱乐部。既然宪法已经崩塌，没有人真正知道是谁在管理这座城市。唯一一个真正看起来有点在掌控局面的人是丹东。丹东成为了司法大臣。他认识到人们渴望复仇。他同意建立一个革命法庭，在此时对保皇党进行首批公开审判。所以汤姆，你谈到了断头台，关于断头台的那集精彩节目。我们在8月21日（即起义后11天）迎来了断头台下的第一场政治处决。
insurrection. It's a royalist national Guard official called Colu Longormont. And another aspect, you read that Timothy Tackett book, The Coming of the Terror. Brilliant book. He's great in all this. This is the moment when you start to move towards, for entirely understandable reasons, they're facing a total national emergency, a police state. The sections are starting to set up surveillance committees. They're demanding more and more public denunciations. They're shutting down newspapers, plays even they don't agree with. And they also make mass arrests. In two weeks, they arrest about 2000 people, not just in Paris, but elsewhere in France as well. Because they think that they're a fifth column, don't they?
受刑的是一个名叫科吕·隆戈尔蒙（Colu Longormont）的保皇党国民自卫队官员。另一个方面，你读过蒂莫西·塔克特（Timothy Tackett）的那本书《恐怖的降临》（The Coming of the Terror）。非常棒的书。他在所有这些事情上都很出色。这是一个你开始走向一个警察国家的时刻——出于完全可以理解的原因，他们正面临着全面的国家紧急状态。各选区开始成立监督委员会。他们要求越来越多的公开告密。他们关闭报纸，甚至关闭他们不同意的戏剧。他们还进行了大规模逮捕。在两周内，他们逮捕了大约2000人，不仅在巴黎，在法国其他地方也是如此。因为他们认为这些人是第五纵队，对吧？
Yeah. They think that as they're facing meltdown on the frontier, so also there is the risk of counter-revolutionary insurrection in Paris itself. And the list of people they arrest, I mean, there are some very familiar names from previous episodes. So there's Beaumarchais, the playwright who wrote Figaro. Antoine Bernave, who, I mean, he was the guy sent in the carriage to bring the Royal family back from Varenne, who'd been carrying on with Marie Antoinette. So he's locked up. He was basically the big man of the revolution a year ago and now he's been locked up. Yeah. Madame de Tuzelle, who was the woman who was looking after the Royal children, who accompanied them to Varenne. And the process
是的。他们认为，正如他们在前线面临崩塌一样，巴黎本身也存在发生反革命暴动的风险。他们逮捕的名单——我的意思是，有一些来自以前剧集的非常熟悉的名字。比如博马舍（Beaumarchais），写了《费加罗》的剧作家。安托万·巴纳夫（Antoine Barnave），我的意思是，他就是那个被派坐马车把王室从瓦雷讷（Varenne）带回来的人，他曾与玛丽·安托瓦内特有过交往。所以他被关起来了。他一年前基本上还是革命的大人物，现在他被关起来了。是的。图泽尔夫人（Madame de Tuzelle），那个照顾皇室儿童、陪同他们去瓦雷讷的女性。这一过程
de l'ombre, the woman who had been very close to Marie Antoinette, a long time friend at Versailles, the Triennon. And then unlike Madame de Polignac, Marie Antoinette's other great friend, who had fled very early on in the revolution, she had stayed and she had become Marie Antoinette's mistress of ceremonies at Versailles and had shown great loyalty. But she is also notorious in Paris as the woman who is supposed to be the Queen's lesbian lover. So she gets locked up. So all these people, a thousand people, Ban Arves and Grunau, some of them are outside Paris, but the vast majority of these people are in Paris. The question is what is going to happen to them because for the time being they are crammed into the Paris prisons, the Abbe prison La Force, all these kind of prisons that are across the city, often in kind of medieval fortresses or converted
从阴影中走出来的，这位曾与玛丽·安托瓦内特非常亲密、是凡尔赛和特里亚农宫长期好友的女性。与玛丽·安托瓦内特的另一位挚友波利尼亚克夫人不同，后者在革命初期就已逃亡，她却留了下来，并成为了玛丽·安托瓦内特在凡尔赛的宫廷女官长，表现出了极大的忠诚。但她在巴黎也臭名昭著，被认为是王后的女同性恋情人。因此她被关了起来。所以所有人，一千人，巴纳夫和格吕纳，其中一些人在巴黎城外，但绝大多数都在巴黎。问题是他们将会遭遇什么，因为目前他们被塞进了巴黎的监狱，阿拜监狱、拉福尔监狱，以及全城各处这类监狱，通常设在中世纪的堡垒或改造过的修道院里。
convents. But you've got all these traitors, these enemy agents as you think they are, what are you going to do with them in the long run? Because in the meantime there have been some dramatic developments to the east. Nine days after the insurrection, 42,000 Prussian troops have crossed the border into Lorraine and there they team up with a 30,000 strong army of Austrians. Four days later the fortress of Longueuil, which is directly in their path, surrenders after a siege of just three days. In the next week the Prussians cover another 40 miles unopposed, thrusting into the heartland of France. By the 30th of August, they have
但是这里有这么多的叛徒、你们认为的敌方特工，从长远来看，你们打算拿他们怎么办？因为与此同时，东部发生了一些戏剧性的事态发展。起义爆发九天后，42,000名普鲁士军队跨越边境进入洛林，在那里他们与一支30,000人的奥地利军队会合。四天后，位于他们前进道路上的隆维要塞在仅仅三天的围攻后投降。在接下来的一周里，普鲁士人势如破竹地又前进了40英里，直插法国腹地。到8月30日，他们已经
reached the last big defensive citadel, the fortress at Verdun. Beyond Verdun is the valley of the Marne and the road to the capital. And in Paris, Danton issues a call to arms. Now he says the terrible struggle begins and in this combat, there is no choice but victory or death. Limey. It's all kicking off. So we'll be back next time, won't we Tom, with a genuinely blood-girdling story. Yeah, we will be looking at the Marseilles and if you simply can't wait for all this massive excitement, then you know what I'm going to say. You can hear it all right now by signing up at therestishistory.com.
抵达了最后一个大型防御要塞，凡尔登要塞。凡尔登背后就是马恩河谷和通往首都的道路。在巴黎，丹东发出了武装号召。现在他说可怕的斗争开始了，在这场战斗中，除了胜利别无选择，唯有胜利或死亡。天哪。事情全爆了。所以我们下次会回来，对吧，汤姆，带来一个真正让人热血沸腾的故事。是的，我们将探讨马赛曲，如果你实在等不及所有这些巨大的兴奋，那么你知道我要说什么。你可以通过在 therestishistory.com 注册，现在就收听这一切。
À bientôt. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。拜拜。这个集数还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。